hi I'm Chet Haase from the Android
development team I work on graphics and
animations and today I wanted to talk
about animation specifically I want to
talk about activity animations so
typically when an activity launches or
even a sub activity you get standard
animations from the window manager and
you can choose the kind of animation
that you want you can load in resource
for this and as of jellybean we also
allow you to specify a thumbnail that
you can scale from and potentially
crossfade from but that's about it
there's not a lot of customization
possible with window animations what if
you want to do something really custom
so we're going to see how to do that
today so if we run this little demo
called activity animations you see as we
have the main activity with these
grayscale thumbnails and we click on one
of those thumbnails and we launch into
the sub activity it shows a detailed
view of the picture and then the text
that goes along with the picture so
again click on the thumbnail it color
eise's the picture it zooms up into the
full-scale view and we see the text
slide out from underneath the picture
kind of nice we can slow down the
animation so we can see it a little bit
more in detail and you see there's also
a drop shadow in there giving you the
effect of the picture really popping out
toward the viewer and then popping back
when the activity goes back to the main
activity so how do we do that so the
main idea behind this is that we disable
window animations because we don't
actually want them to do anything that
they're used to do is doing instead we
launch the sub activity immediately or
we launch the activity that we're going
back to immediately and then we run
custom animations using the normal
property animation system and once we're
into the activity with property
animations you can do anything you want
so again we disable window animations we
get into the activity and then in the
activity we can do whatever we want and
the trick with handling these sort of
interactivity things like launching from
a thumbnail from one into a full-scale
view of the other is to pass the
information in a bundle so that we have
the appropriate information that we can
key off of to get the effect that we're
looking for so first of all let's take a
look at the application manifest here we
can see that we've set up a style of our
sub activity of transparent and this is
something that I've defined in the
Styles XML file so we have the same
transparent
we're say the window background is
transparent this means that when the sub
activity launches it's not actually
going to paint a default color over the
activity that we're launching from which
is the effect that we want we want the
activity to launch immediately but we
don't want that obvious to the user by
seeing someone pick draw a color drawn
in front of the previous activity
instead we wanted to launch
transparently and then do its thing now
one important caveat about transparent
activities is this means that the window
manager in the system is going to be
drawing the other activity behind there
every time the window is drawn on the
screen it's going to have to draw the
activity behind it this could
potentially be a performance issue so
it's not something you want to do in
every situation and if it's a really
complex set of views that you're you're
dealing with there maybe it's not
something you want to do but for this
sort of transient behavior of going from
one activity to the other it's it's a
pretty neat effect but you just need to
be able to determine the correct
trade-off for your own application
anyway let's take a look at the actual
code so there's a few things going on
here one is that we have this main
activity called activity animations we
set up a color matrix color filter
arguably the longest class name in the
android framework and this is to create
the grayscale effect on those thumbnails
so we're loading these full scale images
we're creating thumbnails out of them
now we're setting a filter which will
make them appear as grayscale in the
thumbnail view and then we're going to
launch from the thumbnail into the
colorized view so we're going to set up
grayscale filters on those we're going
to set up a layout we're going to load
in the pictures and add them to the
layout nothing really amazing going on
here and then we're going to set a click
listener so that we know whenever we
click on a particular thumbnail then our
listener is going to kick in and we'll
do the appropriate thing so that happens
down here on click listener so here
we're going to package up the
information that we need to pass to the
sub activity so that it knows where to
launch its picture from we're zoom in
from and what picture to zoom in from so
that it can do the correct animation
into the the full view of that picture
so here we figure out where the
thumbnail is on the screen how large it
is and also the orientation I'll talk
about this a little bit later
and then the resource ID of the picture
so we're going to give all the
information that sub activity needs to
know where and what size to zoom in from
as well as what picture to actually zoom
into and then the text description as
well that's associated with a picture we
put all of this into the extras so we're
going to launch this sub activity with
this extra information and then the sub
activity can extract it now here's an
important point if you're doing this
technique you want to override pending
transitions after you've started the
activity and this will tell the window
manager to back off and not run the
standard window animations on top of
what you're already trying to do in your
custom activity animations okay so
that's all not much going on in the main
activity all the interesting bit is in
the sub activity so let's take a look at
that in picture details activity file we
have various fields that we need we have
a couple of custom interpolators that
we've defined there for the animations
and then we get down here and do the
oncreate this is going to be called when
the activity launches and at that point
we can extract the bundle which is the
information that we packaged up about
the thumbnail that we're actually
launching from so from that we get all
the information about location size the
picture of the text description all that
stuff and then we can actually run our
animations so we come down here this is
an important point here if the saved
instance state is null then we want to
go ahead and run the information if not
then we're actually launching the sub
activity from something like returning
to it from the the launcher maybe
somebody launches your activity from
reasons we don't want to do the custom
animation in that case we just want to
launch the activity with the standard
animation but if the saved instance
state isn't all that we were launched
from the main activity so let's go ahead
and run the animation okay so here's a
technique that I use in a lot of my
animation demos which is a non pre-draw
listener this gets called break before
we're about to draw things which is an
excellent time to track information
that's going to be set up prior to that
first draw in particular we want to know
where everything is going to be like our
main picture view everything's going to
be set up to be rendered in the main
activity and this is the time for us to
kick in and say ok now that we know
where everything's going to be now we
can run our animator
to animate from where it was in the
previous activity into this sub activity
so we handle the on pre draw we remove
the listener because we don't want to
listen to it after this that would be
silly then we get the location on the
screen of the picture that we're going
to we also get the size and then we
create scale factors and this basically
what the technique that we're going to
use in the animation is we're going to
pre scale down to the size of the
thumbnail that we're coming from and
then we're going to scale up to one
right so we have the full size of the
image we're going to pre scale it down
to some fractional size and then scale
it up to one until it reaches the full
size and then we run the rent at the
entry animation here's another important
point if you override on pre-draw
listener return true by default I des
like to have you return false which is
silly because that basically disables
rendering on this frame we wanted to go
ahead and draw the first frame so return
true it's the right thing to do then we
run the enter animation we calculate a
duration based on whether we've enabled
that scale animation property in the
menu no big deal there we set up some
initial values so the pivot point that
we're scaling around were the scale
factor that we're going to scale down to
before we start the animation and then
the translation X&Y so we're going to
scale from a particular size and from a
particular location we also tell the
textview which is going to hold the text
description for the picture to alpha
zero so it's going to be initially
transparent then we're going to fade it
in here's the main animation so for the
image view we're going to run a view
property animator at that duration we
calculated earlier we're going to scale
X&Y into one so it's going to be the
full size of the picture when it's done
translation X and what translation Y
you're going to go to zero from that
initial location they had from the
thumbnail that we're launching from
we're going to have a decelerate
interpolator which means it's going to
start fast and then slow down and lock
into place and then when the animation
ends we're going to run the following
runnable which is going to go ahead and
start the textview animation so we're
going to set the translation Y to be
basically up underneath the picture and
then we're going to animate it down to
translation Y of zero and we're going to
fade it in at the same time again using
a view property animator on the textview
itself in parallel we're going to fade
in a black background so if we see the
the demo again you can see that we're
fading in the background
to this opaque black background behind
the picture once we're finally doing so
that's going to happen in parallel so
we're going to animate the Alpha value
of this background that we've already
defined we're also going to run a
colorizer
animation now this is not a standard
property instead it's a property that
I've defined on this class called
saturation so I just created a property
setter called set saturation which we'll
see down below and we're going to run
that from 0 to 1 and as that runs we're
going to change the color filter which
is going to colorize that image from the
initial grayscale up into the full color
version of the picture and we're also
going to animate a drop show we'll see
how the rendering of this works in a
minute but it's enough now to know that
we're going to animate the shadow depth
from 0 which is basically the shadow is
going to be exactly mapped behind the
image to some offset value which will
then use to calculate alpha as well as
offsets for the shadow and the the idea
here is that we want to start with the
thumbnail starting on the plane that
we're projecting onto and then as the
thumbnail pops out we want the shadow to
help give the illusion that the the
image is actually popping out toward the
user and then we start the animation so
we also have a run exit animation it's
basically the same animations in Reverse
so I won't go through the code there but
there's some other interesting bits to
look at here one is the saturation this
is the property setter that I define
that's going to be called by the object
animator we're going to set the
saturation of the color matrix and then
we're going to define a new filter and
set it on the drawable this is an
important point we can't animate the
filter itself because it's not a mutable
object instead we need to create a new
filter with this saturation value and
then set that on the drawable and that's
how we animate the the colorization of
the drawable itself two more points here
is on back pressed we override this so
that when the back button is pressed
we'd like to go back into the main
activity but we want to animate that and
to do that we need to run the animation
and then finish the activity by default
on back press simply runs finish
immediately what we want to do is run
our animation first which is going to
happen in that method that I skipped
before run exit animation and then when
it's done this runnable is going to
execute
that's going to call finish we also
override finish for the sole reason of
overriding pending transitions same as
before
I don't want window animations to run
when I'm returning to the main activity
because I have my own custom animation
to run only one more detail here is the
shadow layout this is a neat rendering
trick for drawing shadows this is sort
of a general container that will draw
shadows behind all children in this
particular case it's just drawing
shadows behind the one child that the
that our container has which is this
this image that we're animating into so
we set up some initial values here we
use a trick of blurring the edges
because it's kind of nice to have this
sort of blurry anti-aliased edge to the
shadow so we draw a round rect with the
blur into this bitmap and then we're
going to draw the bitmap the appropriate
size whenever we render ourselves this
property setter is going to be called by
the object animator which animates the
shadow depth so it's going to set a
couple of values in here including the
Alpha on the paint that we're going to
render with and then we invalidate this
container so that we can actually have a
chance to render our shadow as we draw
and then on draw we override to actually
draw the shadows behind all of our
children so we're going to walk through
all of our children in this particular
case there's only one but you could see
how maybe there would be several
children where we want to draw with this
shadow so we're going to get the child
we're going to calculate a depth factor
here we're going to set some values on
the canvas that we're drawing with
specifically we're going to translate to
where we want the shadow and then we're
going to go ahead and draw the bitmap
that we created before and that's it
again an important point is transparent
activities aren't a good idea in general
for performance reasons but if you
really want a custom animation going
into that sub activity this is a pretty
good way to go about it you can check
out information about the code itself
add a link that's provided in the
description of the video and check out
the other dev bytes for more animation
information thanks